vor mir haben wir drei Produkte die
absolute Klassiker sind einmal Nudeln
mit Pesto einmal Vanilla Eis und eine
Tiefkühlpizza Margarita auf der anderen
Seite haben wir die Gegenparts dazu und
zwar in der Luxus Ausfertigung teure
Bronze Nudeln ein sehr edles Basilikum
Pesto Madagaskar Vanilleeis und eine
Premium Tiefkühlpizza ich möchte heute
herausfinden ist es das Geld wert statt
dem Klassiker der teilweise eh schon
bisschen teuer ist das Luxusprodukt zu
holen finden wir es heraus und wir
fangen mit Pizza an
[Musik]
okay hier die beiden Bewerber einmal die
frosty Pizza als unsere Luxusvariante
kostet 6 Euro ist von dem Kölner
Restaurant die die Dinger quasi
vorbereiten vorbacken schockfrosten so
dass man sie selbst zu Hause aufbacken
kann klingt schon nach einem sehr sehr
guten Konzept und hier drüben die
ofenfrische es gibt ja noch die
ofenfrische Ristorante wie auch immer
aber ich finde die ofenfrische Dr Oetker
ist so der Klassiker also wenn man
Fernsehwerbung Pizza denkt dann denkt
man an die ofenfrische deshalb ist das
jemand Bewerber Margarita mit Gouda also
das ist auf jeden Fall schon glaube ich
das was den ersten Italiener hier ein
bisschen sauer machen würde die Pizza
nennt sich sogar lavera Margarita also
die echte Margarita und wir haben hier
als Käse das steht hier bei den Zutaten
für die Latte also Mozzarella und Büffel
immerzarella sogar auch also beides
zweierlei wenn wir gerade gucken diese
Streifen das ist für die Latte und die
großen Dinger das ist Büffelmozzarella
das ist halt legit einfach 'ne Pizza
fertig belegt aber noch nicht gebacken
so nicht fertig gebacken ich würde sagen
ich packe die einfach mal beide aus wir
haben hier nicht auftauen lassen 230
Grad hier haben wir 250 Grad und
auftauen lassen also auch die
Zubereitungshinweise sind ein bisschen
unterschiedlich ist die Haltbarkeit auch
unterschiedlich Haltbarkeit 12.6 23 ein
halbes Jahr und Toba 23 also schon vier
Monate länger holen wir mal hier die
Premium Variante raus und die sieht
wirklich nicht verkehrt aus ne also
kannst du echt nichts sagen 6 € finde
ich wenn das jetzt eine echten Pizza
nahe kommen ne wenn das so eine
lieferpizza wäre würde ich sagen 6 € für
eine lieferte Margarita geil Pizzateig
Tomatensoße Käse dann noch Tomaten Pesto
das war's hier drüben haben wir
Weizenmehl Gouda Käse Säuerungsmittel
Gerstenmalz Extrakt Emulgator also das
ist schon mehr so dass naturbelassene
Produkt wir gucken uns aber mal die
Pizza im Vergleich an und das
Interessante ist gerade wenn wir das
jetzt so sehen der Klassiker die
ofenfrische kostet 3,50 €, das ist nicht
mal der doppelte Preis und im Side by
Side kann sich ja jeder mal seine
eigenen Gedanken machen
was soll man dazu sagen Alter also wer
da nicht im klaren Favoriten erkennt
aber ich meine wie gesagt doppelter
Preis ist auch doppelter Preis ne und
die ganzen Werbespots von der
ofenfrische die sich hier eingebrannt
haben muss ja auch irgendwas bezahlen
hier haben wir sechs bis acht Minuten
Backzeit und hier drüben haben wir 12
bis 14 ich würde sagen wir geben die
beiden Kisten bevor die hier weiter
auftaut jetzt in den Backofen und dann
gucken wir mal also mache ich darunter
jetzt überhaupt noch Backpapier muss
eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt ne
so ernst genommen
also durch diese Präsentation auf den
Pizzablech sieht wirklich krass aus
warte warte das Ding ist ich glaube es
gibt diese Pizza auch nicht nur im
Restaurant zu kaufen sondern auch in den
regionalen Supermärkten hier das ist auf
jeden Fall ein Konzept was auch in der
echten Welt funktioniert und boah die
ist richtig knusprig gebacken glaube ich
okay das klingt sehr gut dann holen wir
uns auch mal die zweite Pizza ab
ofenfrisch gebacken man muss wirklich
sagen sie sieht auf jeden Fall
wesentlich besser aus als vor dem
Backvorgang Backofen aus und hier haben
wir sie jetzt nach dem Backen sieht das
Ganze wirklich viel besser aus ich bin
aber trotzdem schockiert die kleinen die
Pizza ist ich frage mich ob die immer
schon so klein war ich hätte die nämlich
so groß in Erinnerung gehabt aber das
ist ja wirklich winzig ich glaube wir
müssen einfach reinschneiden und
unterscheiden das hier kann sich sehen
lassen ne also wirklich schönes Stück
Pizza verneigt sich knuspriger Rand und
hier drüben schneiden wir auch mal eins
raus wer fängt an der Klassiker fängt an
erstmal wieder die Geschmacksknospen
erinnern an das was man so gut kennt
Erinnerung kommen hoch ich werde das
direkt so runterspülen mit Cola so
Teenagerzeit so Mama war arbeiten was
mir gerade auffällt sehr teigig im
Geschmack man merkt halt schon jeder bis
es gleich ist halt ein reines
Industrieprodukt ne rechts süße
Tomatensoße wahrscheinlich auch mit
Zucker einfach noch gearbeitet und was
mir halt wie gesagt sehr auffällt ist
dieser teigige Teig das ist unsere Luxus
Pizza nicht lang schnacken Kopf in
Nacken würde ich sagen können wir uns
ein bisschen Frost die Pizza 350 6 € los
geht's
boah Käse macht einen großen Unterschied
sehr knusprig noch knuspriger als drüben
eigentlich schmeckt auch ganz anders
oder weniger Tage was mir gar nicht
gefällt ist das Pesto wenn du so Augen
zu machst wirst du denken dass sie aus
dem Laden kommt oder wird sie dennoch in
eine Tiefkühlpizza Sektion stecken gute
Frage es ist auf jeden Fall schon
vergleichbar mit einer Restaurant Pizza
aber nicht mit einer topftop Restaurant
Pizza finde ich also jetzt noch ein paar
Stunden kann man wirklich sagen wie
krass der Unterschied ist oder wir haben
die Pizzen fast verdrückt und ich muss
wirklich sagen mit jedem Switch fällt so
auf wie süß die ist und wie sehr das
hier einfach eine richtige Pizza ist wie
sie sein sollte sehr krass 3506 Euro die
250 hier würde ich jederzeit wieder
investieren die Pizza ist ja auch noch
größer das kommt ja auch noch dazu das
ist gerade noch aufgefallen ist wenn die
Frost die Pizza so viel wiegen würde wie
die Dr Oetker Pizza beim gleichen Gramm
Preis dann würde sie nur 25 Cent mehr
kosten ich finde mit der Information ist
der Sieg noch klarer und geht eindeutig
an die prostitut Pizza weiter geht's mit
Eiscreme und wir haben jetzt zwei
Kandidaten einmal der absolute Klassiker
Krimis Eis Bonbon Vanille und Löffel
zarte Milch
ich bin gespannt wie viel davon wohl
darin ist und hier drüben Lavia Gelati
esorbetti vanilia malagaskar wow
kostenpunkt hier 1989 für 1300 ml 650 g
und hier drüben 6,99 € für 520 ml 400
Gramm sehr interessant hier ist das
volumenfest das Doppelte vom Gewicht und
hier drüben ungefähr das 1,3fache
deshalb auf jeden Fall mehr Luft drinne
mehr Luft drin aber es heißt ja auch
Cremissimo vielleicht ist es deshalb so
Löffel Bar luftig aus lässt sich
wirklich so perfekt rausziehen Jo Jo Jo
okay komm einfach mal so ein fetten
Löffel rein können gerade aus dem
Gefrierfach direkt genießbar schon sehr
krass wir probieren mal
sehr luftig sehr sahnig es schmeckt
jetzt nicht krank nach Vanille schmeckt
wirklich vor allem nach Sahne ein auch
sehr luftig aber auch ein unverkennbarer
Geschmack absoluter Klassiker und auch
so ich finde Konsistenz und Geschmack
verleiten dazu viel davon zu essen weißt
du jetzt darauf freue ich mich
italienisches Eis Madagaskar Vanille oh
besser als gedacht ja wirklich auch
farblich ne riesen Unterschied deutlich
gelber
so krass boah das ist Welten besser echt
das ist wirklich selten besser so ein
krasser Unterschied schmeckt einem also
mir schmeckt einfach viel besser hat
aber auch trotzdem richtig schöne
Cremigkeit ne auch wenn die Dichte jetzt
nicht so gering ist mehr Eis im echten
drin hat mehr so diese Kristalle und
sowas sagen aber es ist halt einfach
garnelote ist viel besser das ist
wirklich einfach das bessere Eis kann
man gar nicht anders sagen man muss es
ja nicht unbedingt damit vergleichen
aber man kann es ja vielleicht mal mit
einem ähnlich teuren vergleichen
vielleicht mit so einem Jerry's oder so
ja und da würde ich sagen safe den Euro
mehr investieren 1 €. oder Ben Jerry's
kostet auch schon sieben Euro
je nachdem der Unterschied bei der Pizza
war aber noch krasser finde ich also das
kann man machen das ist sehr lecker aber
Pizza war krass wo ich aber sehr
gespannt drauf bin ist das letzte
Produkt dass wir vergleichen bzw die
Produkte wir machen nämlich Spaghetti
mit Pest
[Musik]
die finale Gegenüberstellung Klassiker
Barilla Nudeln Barilla Pesto hat glaube
ich auch jeder schon mal gegessen Nudeln
2 Euro ich sage nicht übrigens das
Klassiker günstig sind 2 Euro Nudeln
3,60€ Pesto insgesamt 5,60€ ist schon
echt viel finde ich aber sagen wir mal
man macht 300g und können zwei Leute
easy davon essen hier drüben haben wir
Nudeln für 5 €, warum gucken wir uns mal
an das sind Bronze Nudeln also so
richtig edle Nudeln aus einer Manufaktur
in Italien 5 € 500 g ist die wunderschön
aus aus Neapel ist das Ganze aber das
ist tatsächlich nicht das was den Preis
in die Höhe treibt sondern dieses Pesto
ist es man sagt der Pesto Genovese und
dieses Pesto kommt direkt aus gehen nur
das kostet im Glas was eigentlich
genauso groß ist wie das Barilla Glas 11
€ 11 € hier 360 hier also wirklich ein
riesen Unterschied insgesamt sind wir
damit hier bei 16 € und hier bei 5,60 €,
dreifacher Preis aber auch dreifach so
nice finden wir heraus guck mal das da
gucken wir einfach Mehl mit raus und die
sind auch doppelte
das ist Liebe das wirklich das ist ein
stolzes Produkt guck dir das mal an guck
dir das mal an alter komm Brösel mit
raus 40 irgendwie so besonders an die so
zu handeln ich bin sehr gespannt wie die
auch schmecken werden einmal auf 12
Minuten und wir gehen auf die Barilla
Nudeln in den Topf Koch ein bisschen
kürzer hier drüben gucken wir mal rein
wow guck mal wie dick die werden und die
Oberfläche ist trotzdem noch so
glitschig irgendwie bin sehr gespannt
wenn man sich einfach nur die Kochtöpfe
anschaut sieht man schon riesen
Unterschied zum einen ist hier das
Wasser relativ klar hier drüben sehen
wir schwimmt jede Menge Stärke schon an
der Wasseroberfläche und allein die
Farbe der Topf schimmert gelb der hier
weiß ganz krass gucken wir uns mal die
Pest die an zunächst den Klassiker
testoster mit Basilikum Zutaten
pflanzliche Öle frisches Basilikum 30 %
Cashewkerne im richtigen Wesen sind
Pinienkerne glaube ich drin Parmigiano
Milch maisfaser Molkepulver Milcheiweiß
Basilikum Extrakt natürlicher
aromensäure Regulator also wieder
längere Zutatenliste hier drüben wie
gesagt 11 € das das finde ich komplett
krass olio extra vergine die Oliver das
ist auch italienisch komplett basiliko
Genovese 26 % Parmigiano Reggiano pinoli
also Pinienkerne fiores Sardo diopie
keine Ahnung was das heißt salemarino
die trapania also mehr Salz drin sehr
überschaubare Zutatenliste keine
Regulatoren kein nix es riecht boah es
riecht schon frisch es riecht viel
frischer als das hier das wurde auch
gekühlt geliefert als ein frisches Pesto
auf die Farbe auch Farbe riesiger
Unterschied es ist schon krass also ich
glaube wir erleben hier was hier drin
sind sogar 20 Gramm mehr also das ist
ein bisschen weniger das teure ich bin
richtig halb jetzt also ich habe richtig
Bock das zu probieren
[Musik]
darauf habe ich gewartet 5,60 Euro 16
Euro nehmen wir eine Gabel von Klassiker
um uns an den Geschmack zu erinnern
Barilla Pesto mit barella Nudeln
ich weiß schon warum ich mein Pesto
gerne selbst und frisch mache das geht
ja auch unfassbar schnell findest du
dieses dieser haltbare Geschmack eine
Note davon schmeckt schon fast ein
bisschen so in Richtung Minze es ist
halt nichtsdestotrotz auch eine Sache
die ich gerade in Schulzeiten richtig
aufgegessen habe das Ding ist das ist
halt für ganz viele Leute habe ich Dir
gelernt und Geschmack von Pesto viele
viele denken so soll Pesto schmecken und
es ist auch auf eine Art und Weise schon
geil also kann man auch nicht anders
sein mein Favorit ist es auf jeden Fall
nicht umso gespannt da bin ich auf die
Luxusvariante frisches Pesto Genovese
mit napoletanischen Nudeln das ist ein
Witz die sind so lang und so und so eine
große Reibung wegen der Oberfläche dass
man sie einfach als Ganzes aufnehmen
kann jetzt haben wir hier die
Luxusvariante mit teure Gabel die ich
mir jetzt hier genehmige deshalb sollte
es wirklich besser gut sein ich probiere
mal
ist halt ein anderes Gericht ne also ist
halt wirklich was grundsätzlich anderes
die Nudeln sind so viel interessanter zu
essen weil die sind ja so dick dass sie
quasi wie so ein garverlauf haben außen
sind die relativ weich innen drin haben
die quasi einen Kern der noch ein
bisschen mehr bis hat dadurch schneidest
du quasi mit deinen Zähnen durch und
hast so viel mehr so ein Erlebnis beim
Essen das Pesto ist sehr gut schmeckt
auch auf jeden Fall mir persönlich
besser als das hier ich hoffe für 11 €
würde ich immer eher selbst machen und
das schon eine brutale Pasta ich würde
sagen selbstgemachtes hat einfach noch
mehr so diese frischen Aromen auch so
der frische Knoblauch drin ist und so
das macht einfach viel aber guck mal das
soll mal einer fragen wie die Leute in
Italien es schaffen passt dann nur mit
Gabel zu essen die haben halt einfach
Kranke Nudeln das ist ein Gericht und
das ist eine Mahlzeit es war wirklich
wieder so interessant heute ich liebe
dieses Format leider gibt es so wenige
Sachen die man gut vergleichen kann aber
wenn ihr welche kennt schreibt sie gerne
unten in die Kommentare ob das Video hat
Euch gefallen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Mal wieder hier oben könnt ihr
den Kanal abonnieren und da unten ist
ein für dich vorgeschlagenes Video viel
Spaß und gebt Gas
[Musik]